what you can't tell who's missing Whoopi
Goldberg head-to-head with Meghan McCain
on the view from her home in New Jersey
what you kind of can't tell was the same
thing that he did no no no one's here
I'm just trying to to make sure you can
hear me as the corona virus pandemic
continues co-host Joy Behar remains in
self-isolation while Whoopie explains
why she's not at the desk with her
remaining co-host I just felt like if I
was going to really try to figure out
whether it was okay to come in and my
brain said you know what until they can
get themselves together the governor and
the and the mayor until they can figure
out what they're doing I should not go
in so that's why I'm still here I am
healthy the doctor was very annoyed with
me and coronavirus was just the topic to
get will be and Meaghan debating from
across state lines the two were
passionately discussing Donald Trump's
labeling of the pandemic as the Chinese
virus the same thing that he did no no
no one's yelling I'm just trying to to
make sure you can hear me I'm simply
saying the same way he came in saying
Mexican and rapists are coming here to
get Americans is the same stuff he's
doing it was effective but it was in
connect it was the point and if any
Asian person who is getting hit as we've
seen in the last few weeks because
someone thinks that they are walking
around with it you can't ask the person
who's leading the country you can't lead
with that you got to be bad at me the
view isn't the only show taking the work
from home approach Savannah Guthrie
co-hosted today remotely this shows been
around a long time 60 something years
but never has this happened before we've
got Hoda in our studio Al and I are
working at home Craig is from home as
well we're gonna actually talk to him a
little bit later this morning I will say
Hoda this was the shortest commute in
the history of the world so when you're
in a big like that
that's where you are
late night Stephen Colbert delivered his
monologue from his bathtub my first
guest tonight as you can see is mr.
bubble followed by a musical performance
by the legendary duo head and shoulders
while Jimmy Fallon and Jimmy Kimmel
taped from home as well I'm actually
hiding in my office right now from my
children we've run out of snacks
we've run out of craps to do we made
macaroni necklaces yesterday today I ate
them for lunch
that's how bad it's getting
[Music]